قال الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين إن
بلاده ستنشر الآن
أسلحة نووية تكتيكية على أعتاب الناتو ،
أعلن بوتين اليوم عن اتفاقية مع
بايلور روس ، وقال إنه
سيتم بناء منشأة تخزين خاصة لهذه الأسلحة
هناك بحلول يوليو ، حيث يمكنك رؤية
حدود بيلاروسيا على حد سواء حليفة الناتو بولندا.
وأوكرانيا وسي إن إن ، مشهد سابق في موسكو ،
تنضم إلينا جيل دوهرتي ،
وهي أستاذة مساعدة في جامعة جورج تاون ،
أم جو ، أعني أننا سمعنا أن فلاديمير
بوتين يحاول مرات عديدة أن يكون
استفزازيًا عندما يتعلق الأمر
بالحقن.  احتمال دخول
أسلحة نووية في هذه الحرب في أوكرانيا
رد فعلك على هذا الإعلان هو أنه
أكثر من ذلك Bluster إذا تم التعامل معه
بجدية أكبر
أعتقد أن ما يحاول فعله كالمعتاد
هو رفع مستوى التهديد وبمجرد
استخدام الكلمة  نووي بغض النظر عن
نوع الأسلحة النووية التي يتحدث عنها أه إنه
مخيف ويحظى بالاهتمام وأنا
لا أقول إننا يجب أن
نقلل من ذلك جيم ولكن أعتقد أنك تعرف
كالمعتاد مع الرئيس بوتين عليك أن
تقرأ الخط الناعم وتضعها  في
السياق ، فما يقوله هو كما
قلتم أننا سننشر هذه
الأسلحة النووية التكتيكية أه أنت تعرف
أسلحة ميدانية أه في بيلاروسيا والسؤال
هو أنتم تعرفون متى سيحدث هذا ربما
هذا الصيف ولكني أعتقد أن الشيء المهم
هو عدم قوله و  في الواقع ،
يقول إنهم لن يضعوهم في
أيدي ألكسندر ولوكاشينكو ،
رئيس بيلاروسيا ،
وقد تكون هذه مشكلة أنه يحتفظ بالسيطرة كما
يقول في يده
بشكل واضح في روسيا بشكل عام ، لذا
أعتقد ذلك  في كل هذه الأشياء بمجرد أن تبدأ نوعًا ما في
زيادة الرهان
عندما تتحدث عن
الأسلحة النووية ، يكون الأمر استفزازيًا خطيرًا في بعض الأحيان ،
لكنني لا أعتقد أن هذا الوقت هو
وقت الذعر أو أي شيء من هذا القبيل
أنه بوتين يحاول التصعيد
لأنه  لديه مشاكل بشكل
صحيح أعني أننا رأينا ذلك مرارًا
وتكرارًا أه في أوكرانيا وهل تعتقد أن
هذا القرار أه سيفرض أي نوع من
التحرك المضاد من قبل الولايات المتحدة أو الناتو أم أنهم
يراقبونه فقط ويرون أنك
تعرف كيف  ما مقدار ما يقدمه حقًا
في هذا الأمر
جيدًا ، لا تنسَ
أه ذكر بوتين أن هناك ست قواعد
يتم الاحتفاظ بها ، وهذا في الواقع أه على
ما يبدو صحيحًا أن هناك ست
قواعد تحتفظ فيها الولايات المتحدة
بأسلحة من هذا القبيل ولكنها في الواقع
تحت  سيطروا على القوات الجوية الأمريكية
وهم في أحواض ليسوا فقط
منتشرين في كل مكان ، هكذا قال بوتين ولقد
رأينا كثيرًا هذه
الصالة الرياضية في حرب أوكرانيا ، أنت تفعل
شيئًا ، حان دورنا.
لفعل ذلك أه ولكن مرة أخرى ، أنت تعلم أنه
يفعل ذلك ، وإذا كان لديك المزيد من
الأسلحة النووية هناك ، ثم
أعتقد أيضًا أنه يثير سؤالًا حقيقيًا حول
سبب موافقة لوكاشينكو على هذا ،
فأنت تعلم أن هذا شيء تخلى عنه
الأسلحة النووية أوكرانيا بيلاروسيا ، لقد
تخلوا عنها جميعًا في أوائل التسعينيات ، فلماذا
يريد أي نوع من الأسلحة النووية
مرة أخرى
بشكل صحيح ، أعني وجيل كنت على وشك
أن أسألك أنني أعني أن بيلاروسيا
ليس لديها أسلحة نووية في أراضيها
منذ  في أوائل التسعينيات
أعني أنه بحد ذاته
أه يمثل تصعيدًا أعني ما إذا
كنت تريد تسمية هذه الحرب الباردة بين
الولايات المتحدة وروسيا أعني أنها أم أنها
استفزازية
إنها استفزازية وأعتقد أيضًا أنها
علامة ضعفك  تعرف على ضعف
بوتين لأن أحد الأشياء الوحيدة
التي يمكنه القيام بها الآن دعنا نلقي
نظرة على وضعه لأنه لم يخرج
الكثير من ذلك الاجتماع مع
الرئيس الصيني الحادي عشر ، وهو الآن ، أصدرت المحكمة الجنائية الدولية
أمرًا باعتقاله
كمجرم حرب ، ثم القتال
في أوكرانيا أيضًا لا يسير على ما يرام ، لذا فإن
الشيء الوحيد الذي يمتلكه فلاديمير بوتين طوال
الوقت هو أسلحته النووية ،
لذا فهو يميل إلى اللجوء
إلى Bluster بشأن تلك التهديدات والتهديدات.
أعتقد أن هذا ما لدينا هنا ولكن في
كل مرة تفعل ذلك يصبح الأمر أكثر
خطورة لأنه سيكون هناك على
ما يبدو أه أنت تعرف أسلحة تكتيكية
في بيلاروسيا